From Game of Thrones to Pompeii, Kit Harington
has taken his chiseled body to screens large
and small.
Reviews never fail to notice just how jacked
this dude always manages to be.
We've noticed, too.
Here's how he does it.
Training with stunt actors
From Game of Thrones' brutal, body-twisting
battle scenes to the sword-and-sandal action
of 2014's Pompeii, Harington has had to conquer
quite a few stunts.
Turns out, this is a solid way to get and
stay in shape.
"Done a lot of physical training for the role.
Training sort of six times a week."
As an actor, Harington has had to manipulate
his body in numerous ways.
One of his favorite ways to push the limits
is by training with stunt actors, thus cutting
out the middleman and learning action choreography
as he trains in a way that's consistent with
the character he's playing.
As he told Vanity Fair, his role in Pompeii
demanded daily training for four hours in
addition to a very specialized diet.
Working on his swordsmanship
Harington doesn't just train like a fighter
— he wields like one, too.
His workout routine has involved everything
from one-handed swordsmanship to dual wielding,
ranging from fighting that employs lightweight
sabers to the kind that incorporates the weighty,
long-handled broadswords that Jon Snow most
commonly uses.
His sword training was so intense for Pompeii
that the Game of Thrones staff noted a change
in his technique.
Thanks to all that training, he returned to
the celebrated fantasy series as a much more
fluid and physically skilled actor.
A specifically calibrated diet
Exercise is only part of getting in shape,
of course.
It has to work harmoniously with a lot of
other things, from a solid sleep schedule
to adequate hydration and mental wellness.
But above all, it must be paired with a well-balanced
diet, attuned to the individual's needs, and
that's exactly the kind of diet Harington
follows.
Here's how Harington honed himself into a
lean, mean machine for Pompeii:
"I went on this vigorous regime of over five
weeks of eating over 4000 calories a day."
As Harington told Men's Health, he
"was eating all the time: loads of good carbs,
like brown rice and sweet potatoes.
And lots of chicken."
Of course, that can get boring fast, which
is where so many aspiring athletes fail.
One of Harington's trainers said the key is
in the seasoning.
With the right preparations, even the humble
sweet potato can taste a thousand different
ways.
Personally, he recommends a special blend
of salt and 15 herbs called Herbamare.
Cable-based workouts
Picking any one exercise can be overwhelming.
While the plethora of information on everything
from hyper-specific diets to confusing weight
machines can be a boon at times, it can also
be a curse.
How does one choose where to begin?
How much time is any one person willing to
devote to trial and error?
When it comes to Harington's workouts for
Game of Thrones, there's one type of exercise
that has proven more useful than the rest:
cable-based workouts.
His trainer, Dalton Wong, developed a program
that uses these exercises to mimic his in-character
moves.
He told Men's Journal:
"We were doing… lots of cable routines that
would allow his body a fuller range of movement."
Given that he's usually swinging his sword
wrapped in layer upon layer of heavy fur and
leather, it sounds like working with flexible
cables is exactly the right course of action.
Hitting the largest muscle groups
Strength training has become more and more
popular over the last few years.
As Harington has spent most of his career
playing brawny dudes with physical jobs to
do, he's devout to the practice.
But he doesn't just devote himself to any
old strength training regimen — he focuses
specifically on what will get him the best
results.
His trainer Dalton Wong focuses specifically
on training Harington according to his largest
muscle groups, developing routines that strengthen
his back, legs and glutes.
These exercises — largely deadlifts, lateral
lunges, and upper body push and pull movements
— are done for 45 minutes to an hour, at
a pace so intense the exercises double as
cardio.
As anyone who's seen his muscled physique
on screen can attest, this routine is clearly
working.
Always warming up
It's not enough to push one's body to the
absolute limit.
The serious athlete has to spend time warming
up.
Harington is dedicated to what is an essential
part of any routine, and warming up has kept
him in fighting shape.
Wong shared one of the workout routines he
developed for Harington, and a good third
of it focuses solely on warm-up exercises.
Warming up is the kind of thing that novice
gym rats often skip, since it can seem like
such a waste of time.
But the consequences of diving right into
training without warming up can be devastating.
Instead, be like Harington.
Be committed to getting your body ready for
the thorough workout that ensues.
Changing up his routine
When all is said and done, even the most perfectly
calibrated routine can't trump stagnation.
That's why having a variety of activities
is so important to staying in shape — a
tenet that Harington lives by.
In 2016, he noted:
"The physical stuff is very much a part of
who Jon Snow is.
I've got into rock climbing, ice climbing,
sword fighting, and horse riding."
So what have we learned?
One cannot live by squats, pull-ups, or diet
alone.
We have to adapt, shake it up, and try new
things.
"High intensity interval training keeps me
in shape for fighting wildlings, while they
increase muscle mass.
Helps me defend the Seven Kingdoms against
55-foot giants."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Kit Harington
and Game of Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.